today's question comes from Robert in
California he visits and says we're on
baby step 3 be saving up for a down
payment on a house debt-free except the
house and I have our emergency fund in
place trying to figure out what we can
afford I know you say House members
should be around 25 percent your
take-home pay on a 15-year fixed-rate
mortgage but houses in Southern
California and we live are so expensive
what do you suggest for hot markets like
ours we feel like we can't find anything
reasonable that's going to fit in that
range Robert if you live in California
or you live Southern California or you
live in San Francisco where you live in
Manhattan they do not issue a pass on
mathematics mouths doesn't count you're
in California sorry it counts and the
bottom line of our guideline is simply
this regardless of where you live
whatever reason you use and however
valid the reason is or isn't if you end
up with a house payment that is a large
percentage of your take-home pay you're
going to struggle financially duh we
call that house poor and if you want to
be house poor and blame it on Southern
California real estate prices it's a
reasonable blame I mean yeah prices are
high the thing is can you afford to live
there if you don't make enough to live
there then we've got another issue and
you know there there are people that do
not make enough money to live in
Manhattan it's too expensive there are
people that don't make enough money to
live in X neighborhood whatever
neighborhood you want to name or
whatever city or sub city or borough or
county or whatever it's too expensive so
the thing is you either you know you
cannot tie up forty fifty percent of
your income just because you live in an
expensive area that means you don't make
enough to live in that area is what it
says and so it's up to you you can do
whatever you want to do but I can tell
you that it is very difficult to prosper
financially when you get a house payment
there's a north of 30% of your take-home
pay you can qualify for that much and
people do it all the time and they
rationalize it but they don't prosper
financially because they're so far in
debt they can't breathe the house owns
them they don't own it the house becomes
a curse rather than a blessing you don't
get a pass on math because you live in
an expensive market I've got some these
other markets that are the prices are
just exploding Phoenix is exploding
Denver whoa
Denver's gotten really expensive and you
know there's entire articles and studies
being done on the people to work at
service type jobs cannot afford to live
in Silicon Valley so they're having to
ship in people to work as service jobs
because you can't afford to live there I
mean it's a multi bazillion dollar
market as an example you know and it's
just you can't afford to live there you
can't afford to live there and this is a
microt of that same discussion and so
you've got to decide are we going to
live in a Mar in a house in an area with
a bit of a commute or in an area that's
not necessarily our first choice in
order to prosper financially or does
this make us stop and say whoa we don't
really have them make enough to live
here
maybe we need to think about that